[Music]
so
hello
hi hello
good evening
welcome to the table my name is karen
miner i'm so glad you're here tonight
and i'm also glad those of you who are
watching online are here tonight as well
and we
we have a great night in store from the
worship to the message it's a really
great night to be here i just have a
couple of announcements to get us
started
first we are having a welcome to the
table class
that is coming up next sunday
uh one week from tonight immediately
after the service for those of you that
are new to the table
uh if you've just been visiting for a
while you have more questions about who
we are what we're about what our guiding
vision and mission and values are this
would be a great class for you to be a
part of
this will be offered in person as well
as online so if you're interested you
can see brett after the service to rsvp
for that and then
our online visitors can sign up for that
class using the link in the comments i
believe james is going to put that up
for us so thank you james for doing that
and then let's see
two weeks from tonight three weeks we're
going to be doing our state of the table
meeting and that will also be
immediately after the service state of
the table is basically like state of the
union but on a much much smaller scale
it's where we go through
how we've been doing what we're looking
ahead towards anybody can attend the
state of the table it's not just for
members so if you have a vested interest
or even just a passive interest on
what's going on here at the table
then i would encourage you to join in
for that again that will be just a few
week three weeks from tonight
immediately after the service
before we get into worship i just
thought that it would be nice to take a
beat
we have lives that usually are go and go
and going
and church is such a good reminder to
stop
pause
take a breath
be present
put aside the to do's put aside next
week put aside last week
and just take a breath
i know for me when life gets
overwhelming i can tend to numb out
and not feel and that's kind of my ditch
that i fall into when things are are
getting tough and i read this quote this
uh this week that really resonated with
me so i wanted to read it and then go
into a prayer
this is by
danielle coke she says
don't let your heart grow cold
the world needs its warmth
with every beat life flows out
all that you do will erupt from that
deep well
when the tragedies of this life pierce
your heart like ice
let them be met by the warmth of
compassion
the heat of love in motion
may your heart swell with a desire to
remember all that is true
and right
and lovely and just
let your days be the evidence of a heart
on fire
let's pray
god thank you for the reminder
to be present
to be here right now
to feel all that we're feeling
to not numb out to not avoid
to be here now
and to remember god that you've got us
that your presence is here
and that we are not alone
so god i pray for everyone hearing my
voice tonight
that they would not feel alone that they
would not feel
overcome or overwhelmed by everything
that's going on
but be present to it
surrender it all to you god
remembering that you are good
you are just
you are healing and redeeming
resurrecting
making all things new
[Music]
and we get to participate in that as
well
so god we give you tonight
help our minds and our eyes and ears to
be open help us to feel connected with
each other and with you god
and to be aware of all the ways all the
good ways you're working in this world
all the ways you're orchestrating
it's in jesus name i pray amen
i also want to introduce our worship
leader for tonight you guys can go ahead
and come on in have a seat make
yourselves comfortable
this is
jesse watts and yeah
we love jesse we're jesse fans here
jesse's going to be leading us tonight
he's a friend of the table he's been
with us since the beginning with his
wife tasha we're so thankful for them so
i'm gonna toss it over to jesse and
we'll get started with worship
thanks y'all it's good to be here with
you
uh tonight we have
it's really cool because tonight's kind
of like a reunion of sorts we haven't
gotten to play together in a really long
time
we have joe and ryan and noelle and
i'm really excited to be here so let's
go ahead and stand and we're going to
worship together
i raised
in the presence of my
[Music]
the enemies
i'll raise a hallelujah
[Music]
my weapon is a melody
heaven comes to fight for me
gonna sing
in the middle of the storm
louder and louder you're gonna hear my
praises
[Music]
is defeated the king is alive
with everything inside of me
[Music]
hallelujah
in the middle of the mystery
[Music]
hope will arise
death is defeated
[Music]
louder sing a little louder
louder than the unbelief
[Music]
is the presence of my enemies
the storm
louder and louder
[Music]
death is defeated
the king is
[Music]
is alive
we're gonna move into our prayers of the
people
let me get it pulled up here
[Music]
okay
when we get to
this point um feel free to
speak out any names that you want us to
lift in prayer if you are online
you can just put them in the comments
and karen will read them aloud for us
for the city of saxi texas
and for every city and community and all
of those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the oppressed
with the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them we pray
to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
from online doctors nurses and hospital
employees
karen and daniel
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
is
i'm wonderfully
[Music]
and you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name
[Music]
there's a healing light
just beyond the clouds
[Music]
you make all things
work together
[Music]
for my future
and for
my good you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name
[Music]
you're an artist and departed from the
canvas and the clay and i know nothing
has been wasted no failure or mistake
you're an
[Music]
you're an artist
you make all
[Music]
my things
is
[Music]
you make all
things you make all things
work together
[Music]
for my future
and for my goodness
work together
for your glory
and for
your name
[Music]
so we're going to do a new song right
now which i know is kind of cliche that
a guy comes and visits and teaches a new
song but here we are
uh since we're in this deconstruction
series i wanted to teach you this song
um i went years and years ago i went
through my own deconstruction
um but i was a head pastor of a small
little conservative church in kansas at
the time and i didn't really have a safe
space to go through that so i really
wrestled on my own for a long time
and it really felt like i had this
deep desire
to to experience god and to respond to
god but it felt like every
doctrine or dogma pathway to god i
couldn't take i'm like i just can't take
that path to god
so it felt like there was this giant
like chasm between me and god at that
time and so
i want you to take just take a minute
and put your hand on your chest so you
can feel your heartbeat and let's just
just take a
split second
so we can feel our own heartbeat
what you're feeling right now
with each and every heartbeat
with each
little bump in your chest
it is a proclamation of god's nearness
to you
and so as as as we learn this song where
it says i don't have much but i have a
heart that beats for you
i want us to just know that
even if we don't have the words
if we don't have the strength
even the beating of our heart
shows god our desire to respond to his
love
to his presence
and for me when i went through my own
deconstruction that was the only thing
keeping me going was knowing that my
heart beat
for god
and how can i respond
to the love that you have
lavished on
[Music]
me
how can i respond
to the love that you have
lavished on
me
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you
i don't have much
[Music]
i have a heart that beats
every part of me
and every part of me
wants to love you like you love
me
[Music]
i don't have much
i
[Music]
i have a heart that
i don't have much
[Music]
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heartbeat
[Music]
is
yes jesus we thank you
that when we don't have much our beating
heart is enough
[Music]
we thank you jesus for the reminder that
we are fearfully and wonderfully made
so jesus as we continue to worship
may we slow down
quiet ourselves enough
to recognize your presence in every
moment
and experience deep gratitude
we ask this in your name
amen
if you'd like go ahead and turn to
someone and let them know you're glad
they're here
[Music]
well good evening grace and peace
everybody
it's really great to be with you uh my
name is brett i'm the founding pastor
here and
um i do i want to welcome all of you but
especially those of you who are new
and those who are joining us online we
love you a lot
and um
yeah i know it can take for those who
are are new here we have
i just know it can take a lot of courage
to walk through those double doors back
there especially depending on your
church past and history and all that so
um so take it um
yeah as a small thing that you would do
that so thank you
um
we are let's see well i said actually
last week that
we were in um
part four last week of our series but
that was a lie we were actually in part
five i lost tracks that would make this
part six we've been doing this one for a
while but it is it's just it's a big
topic for those who are um not familiar
so the title is deconstruction finding
god again
and uh this you know this topic
is i don't know it kind of depends on
your kind of enmeshment in the world of
i don't know kind of protestant
christianity to the to the degree that
you're kind of
in that world and on the social medias
and all that you know you've probably
heard
of deconstruction but for those who
aren't um kind of in that loop it's
basically just describing a season of
really wrestling with faith actually
jesse did a beautiful job kind of
describing with his own experience of
you know that that time
where you just feel far from god and all
of the normal pathways
that you had that used to work for you
all of a sudden aren't working and a lot
of the maybe thoughts and ideas about
god like okay i know what i believe i
know why i believe it here we go and all
of a sudden those things are not working
and you don't know if you can believe
anymore and that's um that's a really a
challenging thing so what we're trying
to do in this series is
kind of hit on some of the major
um kind of theological topics and
reasons that people tend to deconstruct
and doubt and kind of wrestle with um
scripture or christian theology or just
what they think about god and the world
and themselves and all that so um and
kind of the hope is that from out of
that we can um reconstruct uh faith well
and um in ways that are really
life-giving and actually you know
helpful and a blessing for us for our
families our society as a whole so at
any rate that's kind of the that's the
series and so the so last week so we've
kind of been all over the place i did a
week on scripture on our images of god
last week we talked about the doctrine
of hell
yes if you missed that one you should go
back and listen to the podcast it was
probably my longest sermon ever um
it was 40 minutes because it's one of
those you know you just open up the can
of worms
and it's like oh gosh i'm gonna get all
these back in in one message uh and
actually this tonight will i don't think
it'll go quite as long but it it's
another kind of can of worms topic where
it might be better as like a class you
know where you could all sit down in a
room and like really work it through for
six weeks but um no matter here we go uh
so it's titled uh deconstruction and
suffering
suffering this is um kind of what's
known as like the problem you know of of
evil and suffering which
is it really becomes an issue for those
who believe um you know in god and a
good god uh it's one thing if you
believe in like like polytheism which is
like many gods because then you just
blame the you know the bad gods like oh
it's their fault you know
and but you can see how with kind of the
idea of monotheism so to speak the one
god uh this becomes sort of a
troubling thing you know of of okay god
is good the god i've come to know in
jesus is pure love itself
um in in god's very self this is who god
is and yet
look around like the just the the pain
the suffering
and we could have i mean heck we could
be here for weeks on end as people came
up and shared their own stories of
suffering and
pain and you know the evil we've
experienced from others i mean just you
know on and on so um so it is this is a
big big deal um topic and
i want to mention before i kind of start
diving into like scriptures and all that
um that there's a book that i drew
really heavily from uh this week that
i've this is a writer i've mentioned him
a number of times and i probably will
continue he's been a huge theological
influence on me his name is david
bentley heart and he
wrote a wonderful book i think it's
probably the best book on the problem of
suffering that i've ever read actually
not i think i know it is it's fantastic
it's about 100 pages so it's not like
you know this academic tome um
though it is he he likes big words so
there's some some big words but so the
doors of the sea uh where was god in the
tsunami is the title of his uh his book
and uh that's a must read if you kind of
find yourself at least intrigued by this
message and you want to go deeper you
know i can't offer you a six week class
right now but i can offer you that book
so um if you want to borrow my copy go
for it just ask me all right um all
right so let's start with with our text
our scripture is going to be from
ephesians chapter 6
of verse 12.
this is the apostle paul writing he says
for our struggle is not against flesh
and blood but against the rulers against
the authorities against the powers of
this dark world and against the
spiritual forces of evil in the heavenly
realms
so
uh many many years ago this is
maybe pushing let's see my little girl
is now 12 not so little um and so this
was before then since we're talking good
13 14 years ago i was speaking with a
friend
and um she's a she's a wonderful mother
very loving very caring um and her her
oldest child her first born uh son he
has cerebral palsy
and um of course this is from you know
from birth
and
she's she's also a christian and has
been for i mean since since she was a
little girl
so we were just i just can still
envision us we're sitting there in her
living room
on the couch and i don't even remember
how on earth i segued that this how we
got on this topic i don't know but um
well if you've ever hung out with me you
know i'm not really one for small talk
so maybe it's not surprising that we got
here but i um
i i
somehow i asked her and it didn't feel
awkward so it must have i must have done
a good job of segue i don't know how if
it sounds weird
sorry but i basically just asked her
like how do you make sense of this like
the god who is love
and your
little boy with you know cerebral palsy
if you're familiar with that you know it
affects the whole kind of nervous system
and the muscles and the you know it's
it's uh really crippling he has a very
severe case so it's it's very crippling
for him and he said how do you how do
you make sense of it how do you
you know do this
and um
i thought her answer it was really
interesting she said basically brett
um
for me i i just have to believe that
this is god's will
um
i have to believe that there's there are
there are just no accidents this is not
an accident this is not random
uh and i just have to i just have to
trust that everything that happens
everything that happens it happens for a
reason
uh and of course i could sense in the
moment
you know this was
she was being very honest and vulnerable
it was beautiful um and so i was not
going to get into any sort of
theological
back and forth you know just
obviously
um but i can't say and so what i said in
that moment i just nodded my head and i
just said i get it
like i get it
um but i'm but i must admit inwardly um
i was somewhat i was disturbed
because
the
the way she was kind of you know framing
that and understanding it um
it definitely seemed to kind of
implicate god in
in this um
this disease that it's hard for i don't
know how you could look at it and say
this isn't um something about this is is
wrong and not good i mean it's obvious
he's suffering and so it would almost
seem to say god is somehow the author
of
the suffering right it's his divine will
it's his and it's just it happened for
for some reason there's some
which we'll actually get to in a minute
there's some
future
that we have to get to but it's it's
worth it uh does that make sense like
it's part of the plan
you know that's even though she wasn't
quite using that exact language but that
was in essence what she's getting
and um
and i was um
yeah i was i really i wrestled with and
i have continued honestly in the kind of
decade plus since then to wrestle with
what is the response there what what
what should we do what what should we
say how do we make sense
um of this because i think honestly her
answer is what i think most christian
how most christians i've interacted with
at least would respond
it would be something along those lines
maybe slightly different language
but something along the lines of you
know look i don't totally get it
i just have to trust
you know in
in god in you know divine providence
that this is all going somewhere and it
will be worth it in the end you know
something something along those uh along
those lines
so um
in his there's a novel
uh the brothers karamazov
and uh it's a it's incredibly powerful
this is one of those russian novels so
it's a you know it's a big one they're
so so wordy um but it's the brothers
karamazov by feodor dostoyevsky and in
it uh so it's a story about three
brothers um
but there's a conversation that happens
about two-thirds of the way through the
novel so dostoyevsky the author just you
know is a christian and incredibly is
brilliant and you really wrestled with
all the beliefs of his day and they all
come out in his novels and so they're
deeply religious i mean this is why i
love i just adore this novel um so about
two-thirds of the way through it
there's a uh it's a conversation between
two of the brothers and these two
brothers could not be more different uh
one is named ivan
and he is the intellectual he's
brilliant a scholar
um he's not
uh
like he's not an atheist because in his
words it's sort of like a backhanded
compliment he says um
i'm not it's not that i don't believe
because i think the the idea of god it
is so
lofty
that i have no idea how a brute like
humanity could ever come up with such a
notion
so so it's sort of like
okay
so you believe you know it's sort of a
strange you know so um
but as you'll see for reasons he's not
really like a believer necessarily
um so that's ivan and then his brother
is named alyosha and alyosha is i mean
just the most good-hearted
person he is he's wonderful he he's um
a deep christian is thinking about kind
of becoming a monk i think actually does
somewhere in the novel kind of joins the
local monastery um in the russian
orthodox you know church and
so two there's the way through novel you
have this conversation between these two
brothers and um the thing is ivan has
been kind of raised
somewhat well he's kind of swimming in
the waters of of um
christian just because he's in russia in
the 1800s so he's familiar with
christianity and he knows his bible and
so he's having this conversation with
his brother and this is what he says he
said okay
so alyosha um
i i want to tell you
why not not that i don't believe in god
but why i must respectfully
return my ticket to him
the picture there is kind of the ticket
of like entrance into the kingdom of god
so why i his word is why i respectfully
return my ticket
and he says i i won't um
i won't kind of frame this in a way i
want to talk about suffering because
that's why he says it's about suffering
but i'm not going to talk about the
suffering of the adults
um because he said although that would
make my argument it would be easier for
me alyosha but i understand that this is
kind of backed his original point about
god you know like
adults can be horrible
and so you know what i'm just going to
put all their suffering to the side
i want to talk about the children
alyosha
that's who i want to talk about
and he proceeds to recount
story after story after story about the
suffering of children um and and there
are other really intense and awful um
we're talking like torture and murder
and just the worst of humanity just the
worst and not like accidents you know
it's like intentional like people being
evil
that's what he tells we actually know um
historians who study this sort of thing
found out that dostoyevsky the writer
had for years been as he's reading the
newspaper he was preparing for this
scene
and he would clip out articles
of the suffering children so it's even
more disturbing when you know that
because you realize it's not just his
imagination coming up with things that
we're all kind of like well yeah maybe
people would do that no these are clips
from
russian newspapers
of actual things that happen and it's i
mean it's just it's i won't go into
details but you know i mean you've seen
the news you know just horrible abuse
and
shame and just pain is just
so so painful um
so he he does all this and here's the
thing this is probably where most kind
of people in their complex relationship
with god like
ivan would probably stop there and say
so that's it aliosh i rest my case this
is kind of the devilish genius of ivan
is that he knows religion so well and so
he says uh and specifically christianity
so he says here's the thing alyosha um
i'm gonna grant to you
or maybe he says like this um
i'll just assume that it is all true
that at the end of all things
um
god really will be all in all
at the end of of all time he really will
kind of unfurl the
um kind of the scroll of history
and show us why it all had to happen
just so this is kind of back to the idea
of the divine plan you know like he says
okay i'll give that i'll grant that to
you he will he will show see the reason
had to have cerebral palsy was because
that led to this and then that thing
then it went here and then that impacted
right and he's like okay i'll give you
that
this is how it's going to play out that
he says as the scripture's saying isaiah
the lion really will lay down with the
lamb
that that christ really will wipe all
tears from all eyes
i i i grant all that um to you alyosha i
even trust that every murderer will fall
down at the feet of those they killed
and beg forgiveness
i i
i'll just go right with y'all yoshi it's
all true it will all happen
but even then
i respectfully return
my
ticket
i i say to that
no
no he said think of it like this alyosha
if you could
bring about an all-encompassing
supreme
blessedness for everyone and everything
at the end of all time but all you had
to do was torture one small innocent
creature to death would you do it
and aliosha just whispers
no
i could not
what's i think what's so remarkable
about ivan's argument i mean you can
tell
he knows his bible
he gets like he's
he's sharp
and and what's so i think powerful about
his argument is a
that he's really willing um to point out
in name the absolute
madness in the world
like yes of course the world it can be
beautiful
i mean who hasn't you know been at the
ocean and observed the sunset or the
majestic rockies or had you know time at
night in the woods i mean yes of course
the world it can be beautiful or
experience you know the loving touch of
someone you care for i mean it's the
world can be beautiful and amazing
remarkable that's all true
and yet also
the world can be absolutely terrible
just the worst i mean i thought of it
this week um it's amazing timing because
i'm writing this message and i'm
watching the news and and i'm seeing
afghanistan just melt down
and
i there was an image that really stuck
out to me and it was it was the picture
of this boy i mean he must have been
about my son dax's age who he's nine
and this kid i mean he's just there you
can see the mayhem around him you know
and there's just like tears falling from
this kid's face
and i just i immediately thought of ivan
i just thought of the children
and
so i think that's a what what ivan's
pushing back on
so powerfully is like look you need to
face the terror in the world
um but but even more than that
um
he also
pushes back on the idea that well
you know this is all the divine plan and
it's all worth it if only we get to the
end game you know then that just sort of
the end justifies the means right that's
basically ivan's what is his pushback is
like no
he says no i reject that like the end it
does not justify the means
absolutely not and that's that's i think
the essence that's the heart of why he's
saying like i j
no i can't
enter the kingdom i can't do it on this
space i just i i return
i return my ticket he says i won't be
reconciled to it
um which is so interesting because i
think
this is off also why ivan i think would
be slightly horrified by often the way
that we as christians
some of our responses to evil and
suffering in the world
because it seems we're probably because
we love god and we kind of feel that god
is somehow implicated in the horror you
know that we
we were trying to reconcile ourselves to
it
you know um but i i think i think he'd
be quite quite horrified and see i want
to give you some examples and just see
if you've
ever maybe said something like this
maybe maybe these things have been said
to you by other christians when you were
in the midst of suffering um and i think
you'll be able to see where ivan
kind of just
just stabs this in the heart i mean it's
just brutal he's like just things like
this everything happens for a reason
you don't have to raise your hand but
you know
everything happens for a reason
uh it must have been god's will
it will all be worth it in
the end
well god must have needed another
another angel in heaven
just think of the lessons you'll learn
now
you you might be imagining i think brett
has dug himself such a hole he will
never be able to come back from this
it's possible because i think honestly
out of all the reasons to be an
unbeliever i think
this is probably like the i think the
most powerful or like the only argument
that makes any sense to me whatsoever
just to be perfectly honest i don't some
of the other stuff i just i don't know
it's just
you know
yeah i was like there's bad things in
the bible yeah well there's also the
most beautiful things that have been the
foundation of western civilization for
like
a long time so you know
but this
is where the rubber meets the road
um
so what i want to actually contend
tonight
is that i think
where we go a little bit wrong is i
think we don't quite understand that
ivan is actually a better christian than
we are
i think i think in essence that's what i
think he's like being the most faithful
and
uh for various reasons
we're kind of like backing away from
what he's doing but i think there's
actually something deeply kind of
subversive in um as you'll you'll see um
i think downright christ-like about um
what he's what he's doing and um
and the reason kind of i say that is
because if you kind of just read through
the new testament
um
you can find almost no examples of
quotes like the thing i just all the
examples i just read those like aren't
really there um for sure you can find
certain hints of that in
certain books of the bible for sure but
not so much in the new testament
which i think should give us a little
bit of pause before we start you know
going down the defend god you know path
or something with statements like that
like just it'll all work out in the end
or god has his reasons you know
something like that um
so
really instead okay so what do we see in
the new testament instead of this like
if it's not giving reasons like that
like how dare you speak against god
that's a little bit of the book of job
by the way if you're wondering other
perspectives that'd be the book of job
like oh who are you peon you know it's
kind of where joe opens up um
and but that's not the new testament
instead
um what you see is something quite
different um the idea is basically that
the cosmos it's not even just about the
world or earth but it's like the cosmos
um is
is actually not to be defended or like
it is all perfect and heavenly like no
the idea is that
the cosmos actually itself
um
is
uh
it is not
operating the way that god intended
that's where the new testament's coming
from
it it doesn't say like yep don't worry
two thumbs up it's it's all part of the
plan don't you worry this is all god's
will like that's not the language of the
new testament instead it says
no
this is um
this is bad
that's basically the new testament is
like yep it's really jacked up and you
say what i thought god created the world
and so how could what he created well
this is where um you get back to what
what some theologians call like the
doctrine of the fall um
of course you have the original
um kind of founding story of this in
genesis um too with you know adam and
eve eating the fruit the apple and then
everything going haywire um i i think
that's um at least from my perspective
that's a a myth but not a myth in terms
of like oh so just ignore it it doesn't
matter i don't mean when i say myth i
don't mean it like that i mean it's a
story
that is trying to point
to a deeper truth
and the deep truth it's naming is that
the the cosmos this this universe it has
suffered some sort of primordial
catastrophe it it has gone
haywire
and
so everything that happens is absolutely
not
god's will handed down from on high this
is where you get into the language like
we i think often as christians um
especially boy we just live in such a
kind of the secular age you know um that
we're kind of a little bit removed from
the world of the new testament and in
the world new testament it is
it's a very kind of spirit and god
saturated world it's very spiritually
minded and so it has no problem talking
about thinking about reflecting on um
evil in the world and not like evil that
somehow god declares is his will but
like forces um
opposed to god in his will operating in
the in the world
um
i want to go to uh a text this is from
ephesians chapter 6 um verse 12. this is
the apostle paul writing and this is
what he says for our struggle
is not
against flesh and blood
but against the rulers against the
authorities against the powers of this
dark world and against the spiritual
forces of evil in the heavenly realms
does it sound like he's like yep
everything that's happening is just the
lord's will is that
does that seem to be his like no like
pretty clearly he understands the world
as
um
as in some sense fallen as lesser not
what god originally intended at all this
is what he he also writes in romans
chapter 8 verses 22 and 23 he says we
know so he's just assuming like of
course you all know you know we know
that the whole creation it has been
groaning
as in the pains of childbirth right up
to the present time and not only so but
we ourselves who have the first fruits
of the spirit we groan inwardly as we
wait eagerly for our adoption to sonship
the redemption of our bodies what is
paul talking about this is um between
ephesians 6 and romans 8 he's really
getting into this idea of the
principalities and the powers
this is the language he uses which is
kind of honestly i think just the best
language kind of new testament writers
had to try to describe evil operating in
the world and not just like well yeah
sometimes humans do bad things but like
more than that like there are there is
some sort of spiritual darkness there is
something that is um
influencing though not even just people
but the world all of creation towards
bad ends
this this is how um
the new testament really thinks of these
things now you say brett you believe in
demons
and um i'd say well
not in the sense of like seeing a demon
around every corner like i get i think
sometimes i you know i just do stupid
things and you know it's not like oh my
gosh the devil the devil made me do it i
think it was a demon oh my gosh why am i
thinking about this you know like i
think we can get more christians have
gone really off the deep end with some
of this and getting almost more
interested in the evil than in the good
and the light
that's not a good path so i'm not
encouraging us to like become obsessed
with the evil and you know let's do
demonologies and like rank all the
demons and think of how they did you
know like okay there's right there's a
way of kind of going off the deep end um
so yeah so not in that sense um but
yes in the sense of of believing that
there is in there are evil forces that
are opposed to the work and purposes of
god in the world
yes
uh and honestly i think it's hard
not to
like look into the eyes of someone who's
at least in that moment really being
like malevolent and evil
and even the most kind of secular
atheist among us might just have that
moment of like
oh my god
what is this
right i i've i don't i'm not one of
those people who's like obsessed with
the true crime podcasts or the netflix
documentaries i just can't do a lot of
those it it's just so dark um i have
seen at least one of them and uh
and i remember like the the kind of
close-ups they do on the eyes of some of
these serial killers and it's like
yeah and those kind of moments that's
when
because i admit like i'm man i've been
raised in this secular world i
it would be very easy for me to kind of
slip into a mode of like oh okay i don't
know about spirits and all that like
okay
and yet i do i have my moments where i'm
like yeah
i think so
even watching afghanistan all that
unravel and it's just like yeah there's
there's even a famous
moment in the life of dedrick bonhoeffer
who was really a christian saint and
martyr but he um was a christian who
opposed nazi germany and hitler and i
don't know how he got this but two days
after hitler was elected to be like
chancellor of germany which he then kind
of
disbanded and became just the fuhrer and
like oh now i'm in charge forever you
know um so this is just two days in
somehow bonhoeffer got on the radio
and like scheduled this air time and
basically just blasted the whole country
and his line i'll never forget his line
is basically some of the effect of my
countrymen who has bewitched you
that's his bewitched which i don't think
even of course like literally like the
witches have done right not that
but it's that it's that sense of we've
seen when a mob goes mad when a nation
goes mad it's like have you all lost
your collective minds what is going on
right that's the moment we're like
oh
so that's why the bible talks about
those right because that that's what
it's trying to name is
our battle it's not just against flesh
and blood
but against the rulers against the
authorities against them um the dark
forces that are powers of evil at loose
in this world there's a a scene from the
movie the thin red line
that oh this is a fantastic film by
terence malik
and
it's a war movie
and there's uh this moment where he
shoots it so brilliantly because you see
these um soldiers are storming this kind
of enemy camp but the camp's been pretty
clearly abandoned because they knew they
were going to overrun but they had to
leave like injured soldiers and such so
you see these storms these soldiers
running in
and they're just i mean they're stealing
they're rifling through things you know
packs putting in their pockets they're
shooting unarmed injured soldiers but
the way malik shoots it is it's
completely quiet
so you don't hear anything you just
watch it
and and what's so disturbing is
he he zooms in at times on the faces of
the soldiers and you can tell there is
no sense of like i just gotta do what i
gotta do it's like there's like a
delight
and he he what he does though instead of
the audio he gives just this voice over
and it's the voice of one of the
soldiers
and this is what that soldier says he
says this great evil
where does it come from
how did it steal into the world
what seed what root did it grow from
who's
doing this
killing us
robbing us of life in light
mocking us with the sight of what we
might have known
i just think that's the moment where he
gets it
where he realizes
that there is some evil that has been
set loose in the world
and
and we we don't
that doesn't put us in the place of
having to ascribe it all to god
and i think even as we think of christ
this is why ultimately if you think of
even how did jesus end up on the cross
what would paul say
it was the principalities and the powers
it was the state
and religion
and evil forces working through those
actors
that's how jesus ended up on the cross
and even if you think of jesus like his
life in ministry
um like when he first is you know
incarnated comes into the flesh and
enters into the world like he didn't he
didn't even enter it in this mode of
like well this should go well
you know like
like can you and yet we would think well
yeah no it should because you know
everything that happens is the lord's
will and so did you know but like no in
his mind he's like entering into enemy
territory like this world is fallen this
place is crazy mad house
and in fact you see that's exactly how
it plays out i mean just think of like
he starts his ministry and what's the
first thing that happens like he's taken
by the devil and tempted right i mean
it's like the gospel they're trying to
say like they're kind of trying to set
us up like hey do you get it this world
is not operating as god intended
i i i love and i'll close it this is a
quote from um david bentley heart
i think he just sums it up really well
he says for after all if it is from
christ that we are to learn how god
relates himself to sin suffering evil
and death it would seem that he provides
us little evidence of anything other
than a regal relentless and miraculous
enmity in other words opposition
sin he forgives suffering he heals evil
he casts out and death he conquers and
absolutely nowhere does christ act as if
any of these things
are part of the eternal work or purposes
of god
can i get an amen
like
sin he casts out or sorry sin he
forgives
evil he casts out suffering he heals um
death he conquers through resurrection
and call me crazy but if that's that was
christ's approach and that's how he
interacted like if he saw someone in sin
it wasn't like well you know what
that'll probably lead to a good end like
don't worry though everything happens
for a reason like no no sin he forgives
like hey let's keep moving forward let's
do better here you know cindy for gives
for someone's suffering it's like well
that you're going to learn a lot from
that i'm glad i'm actually glad that
happened you know like no
he's he's bringing healing everywhere he
can
he's um
i mean so much compassion for the
suffering and then death through of
course the cross and then resurrection
he conquers
and it's all through the new testament
even death itself which we could take is
like well you know death is so natural
it's just the circle of life you know
this circle of life it's beautiful in
its own way
not
from
christ's person not from the new
testament's perspective it's like death
is awful
it's that's bad and our hope is that
through resurrection like god will
restore and heal all things
and um
and so i think this is why those you
know previous statements again
you know everything must be god's will
um
no that's that's not quite where jesus
or jesus is
is coming from
and so um
i think by well coming back to ivan
this is where i think ivan had it right
this is why he was a he was a better
christian because and now ivan was a
little confused because he thought by
saying the divine or not the divine but
by saying no
to these no to death no to suffering no
to like oh this is all part of the
planet he's like no he thought he was
rejecting the kingdom of god he thought
he was walking away from god's will and
so he's like i don't want any part
but actually i think christ would stand
with ivan
insane no and and that means as
christians we then are invited with ivan
to say
god's
no
and which also in the same moment
becomes a yes
a yes for beauty a yes for truth a yes
for compassion a yes for love
and so that's it
that's what i got
um
again i've probably opened up some can
of worms you might have all sorts of
questions and things and you're like
well what about you um
so feel free to chat me up take me a
message whatever you'd like
and i realize this is a heavy topic so
thank you for the for your grace in the
midst of it let me let me pray and
then we'll close with some one more song
lord
we just thank you
god thank you for your goodness thank
you
thank you that you don't ask us to be
reconciled to evil and malevolence in
the world
and i pray over every person here
tonight who
um has suffered and has really wrestled
with how could this be the divine plan
what is
that that abuse that
that shame
[Music]
that violence like what
and i pray god that you
would set them free
that
that they could
learn to even hate those things not the
people
god but the evil and the suffering and
the sin and the death god to hate it
with a perfect hatred
that would then lead to a perfect love
i love the beautiful the good and the
true god so do that work in every heart
and mind
do that work in us as a church community
and we love you god
in christ's name i pray
amen
[Music]
if you're gay and over 85
and you thought for your whole life that
when god made you he just messed up
and if you've been raised a southern
belle
born and bred for show-and-tell but you
lie down feeling never good enough
i'm so sorry
for how it's been
we're broken artists
with broken pens
we paint our pride
and we call the truth
i'm sorry no one explained jesus
[Music]
if you've heard a knock at your front
door
but all that you found on the porch was
a pastor that just wanted to be right
and if you really want to pray to him
but you're never sure he's listening
cause who could forgive what you did
that night
i'm so sorry
for what you've heard
we're broken poets
with silly words
we paid agendas
and call it truth
i'm sorry no one explained jesus
[Music]
can't you feel
all he wants is you
but i'm so sorry
for all the wrongs
we're broken singers
with stupid songs we paint our fears
and we call
the truth
i'm sorry no one explains jesus to you
i'm sorry no one explained jesus to you
i'm sorry no one explained jesus
to you
[Music]
oh
we're so glad that you were with us
tonight
and we want you to know that you're not
alone whether you're in here or whether
you're watching online
so if you need prayer
please come up to me after the service
it would be an honor to listen and to
pray with you
and to be present with you
and if you're watching online and need
prayer just comment and somebody will
get in touch with you
don't forget about our welcome to the
table class it's happening next week you
can rsvp with brett or you can do that
online as well
and then you can also go to our website
thetabletx.org
and get more information there
on giving and meetups and how to connect
we're a community we want to bear
burdens we want to celebrate joys
and we want to be with you
so as we wrap up if you're able please
stand and i'd like to send you out with
this benediction
[Music]
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
unconditional love and grace to everyone
you come in contact with this week
be blessed and we hope to see you back
here next sunday good night
you